The other kind of exercise in our
courses is programming exercises.
Here's a simple programming
exercise from AI for Robotics.
In these exercises you'll have an IDE
available right in the web browser.
You'll be given some initial code
to work from like we see here.
So after you've worked on the exercise
you can click Test Run at the bottom.
The output of your code
will be displayed below.
Then, when you're satisfied with your
code, you can click Submit on the right
and you will see your
evaluation on the right.
>> We have some courses that
actually use this code window for
project submission.
You'll develop the project
on your local machine, but
you can use this window to test and make
sure that your code actually runs, and
maybe see some preliminary output.
For those courses,
when the TAs go to grade your project,
they'll pull the last thing that
you submitted before the due date.
So make sure your last submission
is the one you want to turn in.
But you don't need to worry
about that too much right now.
That will be explained in more detail
when you get to those actual classes.
Now over here on the right, you've
probably noticed that every screen
suggests that you take up
this conversation on Piazza.
Piazza is the forum tool that we use
right now in the OMS program, so
let's talk about that next.